y con nuestro primer invitado del día
vamos a analizar la importancia de la
gira del presidente estadounidense joe
biden por medio oriente para ello le doy
la bienvenida al doctor lajos szaszdi
león borja analista de relaciones
internacionales y estudios estratégicos
profesor adjunto de la universidad
interamericana de puerto rico doctor
layos gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france a 24 por
supuesto quiero empezar entonces con el
contexto la importancia digamos de esta
gira en todo el contexto mundial que
estamos viviendo en este momento la
guerra el petróleo la recesión económica
sí bueno ese se ha dicho que una de las
razones importantes de esta gira aparte
de fortalecer la sociedad es con israel
por parte de la administración by de que
ya había visitado de pues decenas de
veces creo no no menos de 10 ahora no
recuerdo el número pero lleva pues como
unos 50 años y habiendo visitado va a ir
en conmocionado primero después como
vicepresidente de obama y ahora la
primera vez como presidente no menos de
diez veces
y es una forma de realzar esos lazos con
israel sobre todo cuando me atrevería a
decir que el presidente obama pues no
tenía muchos amigos o había parte de la
opinión pública política y en general en
israel cuando mamá era presidente que lo
consideraban como que no era tan amigo
de israel lo cual no es cierto sí que lo
era y sólo posible todo lo que pudo por
el estado israel para mí esa actitud ese
estigma y baile que era su
vicepresidente así que esto sería una
forma de fortalecer pero aparte de eso
está el tema energético la visita a
arabia saudita muy importante porque
vaivén cuando hizo campaña política como
presidente pues acusó pues al que sería
el hombre fuerte de arabia saudita el
príncipe heredero mohamed bin salman de
pues es básicamente diríamos un criminal
por el asesinato del periodista que yogi
saudí en estambul antigua constantinopla
y en el consulado saudí de la ciudad en
turquía
y que bueno haría que arabia saudita se
convertiría en un estado paria si no
mejoraba los derechos humanos una
postura de ese tipo que claro no era no
fue bien recibida en riad entonces ha
habido roces entre washington de se
combaten como presidente y rial desde la
presidencia de bailén así que
uno de los problemas fue que con la
crisis de la subida de los precios del
petróleo
anterior incluso a la invasión rusa de
ucrania como ella recordaremos el tema
éste de pues el aumento de la demanda de
gas natural en la china y la el de
aumento de la demanda de los
consumidores a nivel global tras las
limitaciones que hubo no por el cob y
1913 pero a eso se unió la guerra de
ucrania y claro el tema del petróleo y
del gas rousselon europea por ejemplo
bueno el punto es que ante la subida
excesiva de la gasolina en eeuu que
bailén atribuye a la guerra de ucrania
los republicanos dice que es anterior a
eso pero bueno el bar avisó dita con la
intención de pedirle al hombre fuerte de
saudí príncipe heredero mohamed y salman
que aumente esa producción de petróleo
para del reino saudí para a ver si eso
contribuye a la bajada de los precios
petróleo porque como saben acabo este
punto rápido ahora se ve incluso el
echado mano la reserva estratégica de
petróleo de eeuu andan buscando cómo
tratar de reducir esa subida de los
precios que además se extiende no a los
precios del consumidor por costos de
transporte ahora en el verano por la
cuestión del calor no los aires
acondicionados después del invierno si
ellos hay dos puntos también importantes
de lo que fue digamos esta reunión
bilateral entre el primer ministro
israelí en funciones ya el lápiz y el
presidente joe wright en el programa
nuclear iraní y por supuesto también
este conflicto entre israel y los
territorios palestinos vamos a empezar
por ahí esta afirmación de bailén
nuevamente decir que cree que este
conflicto se puede determinar en la
solución de dos estados a qué tan cierto
digamos y qué tan lejos o cerca está
realmente de finalizar este conflicto
con estos dos estados
bueno digamos que ha quedado un poco en
el asiento trasero da la impresión el
tema de pues la independencia de un
estado palestino un estado palestino
independiente y una solución al
conflicto árabe-israelí con dos estados
el estado de israel y el estado
palestino él jake sullivan él se
considera seguridad nacional de bailén
ha dicho de que bueno pues eso
eventualmente
eventualmente será así lo de los dos
estados pero que de momento no es
realista algo así en esos términos lo
dijo ahora es tema complejo sin duda lo
dirán porque bueno vamos a empezar por
alguna parte israel que quieren que se
detenga el programa nuclear iraní por
todos los medios bardem quiere revolver
a un acuerdo nuclear como el que firmó
exitosamente el presidente obama y sus
socios con irán en 2015 y que en 2018 el
presidente trump se salió entonces pues
se irán ya ha dicho que no quiere el
acuerdo del 2015 en todo caso quiere un
nuevo acuerdo y entre otras cosas que a
la uar a la guardia revolucionaria o los
guardianes de la revolución iraní
pasdarán que es la fuerza de élite
militar del régimen iraní pues que los
saque de la lista de organizaciones
terroristas ya washington incluso leí
estás considerando eso pero eso no le
gusta israel eso no le gusta el hecho no
solamente que se preserva el programa
nuclear iraní pero incluso que a los
guardias de la revolución iraní pues los
saquen de la lista de organizaciones
terroristas porque están enfrentados
israelí ellos por ejemplo en el campo de
batalla de siria entonces eso por un
lado pero mira es más complejo no
solamente el tema de que es israel no
quiere el acuerdo nuclear y bailén si lo
quiere también se está hablando de un
acuerdo de defensa aérea regional
incluyendo arabia saudita también creo
emiratos árabes unidos países árabes del
golfo pérsico pero no se ha hablado creo
que del tema en esta visita será caso
para no ofender a los negociadores
iraníes en todo caso el bailén ha visto
un sistema de defensa antimisil en el
aeropuerto ben gurión y ahora ayer
cuando llegó y ese tiene varias capas
varios niveles de defensa del más bajo
que es el domo de hierro contra cuenta
en artillería la honda de david que
sería contra aviones aviones no
tripulados por ejemplo el sistema arrow
3 a rock free flecha 3 contra misiles
balísticos y un nuevo sistema domo de as
de hierro
iron beam que es con la ser un arma
láser para interceptar vehículos aéreos
pues cuentas artillería me imagino
misiles eso por un lado y eso es
relevante para la guerra decir perdón de
ucrania que es si tomamos en cuenta que
el peligro de una guerra entre rusia y
la otan es bastante alto y ya se ve que
el uso la artillería es sumamente
importante autrán ya le faltarían
algunos de esos sistemas que tiene
israel otro tema rapidito si él
el día del foro y
212 de cooperación económica que va a
ser virtual qué es eso de idos israel
india u 2
united arab emirates emiratos árabes
unidos eeuu un peregrinaje de stage y
eso es para la región indo pacífico muy
importante porque en mi opinión podría
tener una extensión militar ya que
israel exporta muchas armas de la india
y hay esa alianza entre la india eeuu
japón australia ante la amenaza china